Mariah Carey shares her extravagant way
of life on the series premiere of
Mariah's world
Brian's eight-part docu-series premiered
on Sunday and it was chock-full of
over-the-top moments this was a surprise
from James look this is the first
episode featured the singers now
ex-fiance James Packer and their wedding
planning process we have great moments
together I find a wedding dress that I
really love it was made for me
however Mariah and billionaire have
since called off their engagement prior
to the airing of the show Tanaka
does have a crush on her you saw it he's
not leaving that easily
Mariah's rumored flame and backup dancer
Bryan Tanaka also made an appearance we
learned the to actually go way back they
first met in 2005 when he was quote a
young buck et's Carly Steele spoke with
the diva last month where she played coy
about the status of their relationship
it's a potential romantic intrigue I
enjoy your just me just being dramatic
but Bryan and Mimi's romance could be
heating up they were spotted on vacation
in Hawaii just last week
[Music]